oh no i can't with
the coffee before teeth brushing hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by ritual and
we are back with another celebrity
harper's bazaar what i eat in a day
review and this time we're going to be
looking at
youtube darling and fashionista emmer
chamberlain
now i'll be honest emma really was not
on my radar until you guys requested
that i review
this food diaries video specifically so
that to me is generally a good sign
that she doesn't fall into the category
of the more problematic
wellness influencers that i typically
review i also started to watch
a lot of her content for another fun
video i'm working on about reviewing
influencers breakfast
so you'll definitely have to stay tuned
for that
but i do think it's safe to say that
like the rest of her 10 million
subscribers
i'm kind of obsessed now before we get
into today's video
i want to talk for a minute about my
personal supplement routine
because i do get asked a lot about this
often in my dms
so as a lot of you know i'm not pregnant
anymore
but i am exclusively breastfeeding and
that takes
a lot out of me literally and
figuratively
so i actually still take my daily
prenatal vitamin for ritual
every night before bed as part of my
overall bedtime routine
so generally my bedtime routine consists
of bathing my kid
in my bathroom these days so while i'm
like running the bath i'll wash my face
and then i'll get out
all my supplements and my prenatal is
definitely one of my
non-negotiable staples i know the
supplement world is really overwhelming
but i like rituals prenatal because it
has 12 high quality nutrients to support
the health
of me and baby before and during
pregnancy including methylated
4th generation folate vegan b12 d3
and omega-3 and they've got no colorants
additives or unlisted ingredients
it's also vegan sugar-free gluten-free
and allergy free so
if you have a hard time finding a
vitamin that fits your unique dietary
needs
this really does have it all also if you
find that taking a prenatal can make you
feel a little bit
nauseous these ones have a no nausea
capsule design so you don't necessarily
have to take them
with food so you can take it in the
morning when you wake up
or before bed like i do really whenever
you remember
but if you're wondering when to start
taking a prenatal
i would say like always if there's a
chance that you might get pregnant
but definitely three months before you
want to start trying
and if you're nursing like i am you can
continue to take it post-natally as well
just to replenish all of those nutrient
stores they also have a regular
multivitamin for men
and women as well as a 50 plus option
but it's super convenient because they
just deliver it to your door as part of
the subscription so
even when i'm having super mom brain i
won't run out
so if you want to try it out you can use
my promo code and check out the link in
the description
to get 10 off of your first three months
of ritual
also very quickly you can check out my
disclaimer here on screen so feel free
to pause the video if you want to read
it
or you can check it out in the
description below also don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a video
all right folks let's take a look i get
right out of bed don't brush my teeth
don't wash my face i go straight
downstairs
to either make my first coffee or go get
coffee with someone
uh i mean to each their own but this
kind of offends me
on a personal level because this is what
my husband does too
and i do not understand it
how can you enjoy any part of your life
before you wash your face and brush your
teeth
ugh i don't know i just like
can't relate to that one um but do tell
me below if you brush your teeth before
you drink coffee
or after i need to know i need to know
where
i stand in this very heated hot topic
but anyways i would hope that she would
at least brush her teeth before having
coffee with friends
otherwise emma's friends be watching
this right now being like siri
note to self decline early morning
coffee with emma currently declining
early morning
just kidding girl i would probably look
past it too for a coffee date with the
coffee queen but anyways let's see what
she has to eat
so i'll usually make a latte
and i take two shots of espresso put
some vanilla almond milk in it
unsweetened and then i put vanilla nut
pod
creamer in it and that's my home recipe
interesting uh normally i don't have
much to say about someone's coffee of
choice because
i feel like coffee is such a sacred part
of our day
that it has critique immunity like even
from me
um but because emma is known for her
coffee
i just kind of want to dissect this just
a bit for funsies
um now even though emma is a coffee
connoisseur of sorts
i love that her coffee order is
something that i legit
easily could make at home if i wanted to
and i guess i was just expecting more of
like a bougie almond milk than the
khalifa brand
because i have personally used that
stuff to try to make a latte before
and it does not fall which sucks because
i don't know a latte
has got to have a nice solid foam
i don't know i've experimented with a
lot of non-dairy milks in my frother and
i personally
have had more success with the barista
blends
which are specifically designed for
getting that nice aerated layer on top
but typically speaking milks with higher
amounts of protein content
are better for foaming because the
protein molecules essentially
help to maintain air bubbles that are
created during the frothing
process and since a lot of non-dairy
milks are so
low in protein they just kind of sit
flat
so if you are pining for a coffeehouse
latte at home
look for one of the non-dairy barista
blend milks at specialty stores
they do tend to be a little more
expensive but still
way cheaper than buying starbucks every
single day
also that was a really interesting
addition with the creamer that was a
curveball
i did not anticipate but now clearly i
feel like i need to try this
all right let's take a look at her
breakfast two overhard eggs
salt on it pepper on it everything but
the bagel seasoning on it
and then i put some cholula on that and
then
i cut up a whole avocado put that on top
and then i eat it and that's my
breakfast every day so
like i alluded to earlier i've actually
been researching emma's avocado toast
recently for another video
that i'm working on and i love
everything about this meal right here
minus the fact that she likes her yolks
hard because
in my personal opinion egg yolks have no
business being cooked through like
it is runny or bust to me so i basically
did not eat eggs at all my whole
pregnancy because
just why but anyways emma
girl i respect your choice so i'll try
not to yuck your yum
you do you but i do love that we have
some quality protein to pair with the
healthy fats and the fiber rich carbs
and the avocado toast
and the everything bagel seasoning come
on
any abby's kitchen blog fan will know
that i am
totally on board with that let's see
what else she has to say
sometimes i'll work out but sometimes i
like working out more at night i really
just shove in a workout wherever i can
fit it
i try to work out four to five times a
week i love how relaxed this girl is
about her food and fitness regime you
know she's like
yeah i know exercise is good for me i
try to fit it in when i can
but hey if it doesn't work out one day i
don't punish myself
and i move on yes that is how we build a
healthy
relationship with our body let's take a
look at lunch
lunch for me is the neglected meal
okay i don't think about it much and
it's
always post mated i never cook lunch
i hear you on lunch being like the
neglected meal i
also don't have time to cook lunch
usually either it's usually just like a
compilation
of leftovers or something store-bought
or pre-prepared
or literally random bites off of my
kid's plate
so yeah i get that it's pretty hard to
find time in the middle of the day
to prepare something from scratch
recently i've been ordering this salad
from this restaurant called
zinc and it's kale lentils
carrots hard-boiled egg sometimes i'll
get
like a burrito or burrito bowl from a
place called takaya in la
or erwan honestly i could go to air one
for every single meal
sometimes i'll just get a crazy like
vegetable
plate thing from there okay all of these
lunch options
sound legitimately delicious uh
that kale salad has a really nice
balance of fiber and protein and healthy
fats
and i also really like her hack on the
burrito where she added cauliflower rice
to boost up the veg
i actually think that this is a really
balanced not restrictive
options since you're still going to get
a good amount of carbs
in the wrap itself and the beans and
this way you can sneak in some produce
into a typically low veg restaurant kind
of meal
also buffalo cauliflower always a good
idea in my books
i actually have a few great recipes on
my blog so i'm going to link those below
for you to check out
all right let's see what else just say i
grew up vegetarian so i've never had
meat in my diet
i continue to be a vegetarian mainly
because i'm a picky eater
so picky eating in adults is actually
more common than people think
and i know a lot of you have messaged me
about this especially after the video
that i did
on dealing with picky eating in kids and
what you can do to avoid it
in fact a lot of the same techniques
that i mentioned for kids
can be used for adults struggling with
this as well
so one technique that we often use is
called food
chaining this would basically mean
making very small changes to preferred
safe foods and gradually building on
them to eventually land at
another less liked food item so for
example
emma mentions that she doesn't like
cottage cheese i love cottage cheese
but let's say that she does like greek
yogurt
she could start with greek yogurt and a
tiny spoonful of pureed
cottage cheese mixed in and then slowly
shift the ratio
until it was all pureed cause cheese
then she could puree most of the cottage
cheese and leave a few of those lumps
left in and then slowly shift that ratio
until was all just like the lumpy
cottage cheese
another example was that she doesn't
like mushrooms so she could start with
ground beef with a tiny bit of minced up
mushrooms
again shifting the ratio until it was
all cooked ground mushrooms
and then she could slowly start to
increase the size of the mushroom pieces
over time but i will say that the list
of foods that she mentioned
are commonly disliked foods anyway i
myself also have a thing with mayo
i don't know it's just gloopy i don't
know what it is
tell me below if you also think it's
weird and kind of
gloopy so if at the end of the day you
really are trying to like selling and
you just don't
then that's totally normal and it's
totally fine you don't need to force
yourself to like
something if it just is not going to
happen for you
but of course in extreme cases of picky
eating
this may be diagnosed as something
called avoidant restrictive
food intake disorder or rfid
in which case you would definitely want
to work with a dietitian who specializes
in this field
let's take a look at snacks i'm a big
snacker
my favorite snack for the past year has
been
these flax crackers they're called
mary's gone crackers
um another snack is i make little mini
cauliflower pizzas
because i found these little cauliflower
thins and i just put a little bit of
marinara sauce on a little bit of pesto
a little bit of vegan mozzarella
bake that for a little bit okay so all
of these snacks sound like really
nutritious choices
and i love that she doesn't describe
them as foods that she eats because
they're
you know super clean or low in calories
or detoxing whatever
i mean even the cauliflower crust pizza
she eats
it's like she eats them just because
they're easy and they taste pretty good
to her
but also i'm totally stealing that idea
i actually
think that a brand sent me these same
little cauliflower bread things
um and i love that they had some protein
and fiber in them
and also they actually had more flavor
than just like a regular piece of pita
which i use all the time to make little
pita pizzas
anyone else like pita pizzas
so great such an easy lunch or dinner
option
to use up little pieces of veg that you
have left over in the fridge
and her version is so much more fancy
with like the pesto and the sausage and
the nooch
but i also bet that they're really
satisfying and pretty delicious too
i also love those mary's gone crackers
they've got some fiber and protein and
healthy fats in there
and paired with the hummus that would be
a super satisfying
and tasty snack and the peanut butter
and plums
can't go wrong with either of those all
on their lonesome
but of course you could pair them
together for an even more balanced
and satiating snack ooh a little toast
with peanut butter and sliced plum on
top
that would be really good let's see what
else she has to say
so recently i've been drinking iced
herbal tea another weird drink though
that i have is sparkling water with
apple cider vinegar in it it helps with
my digestion
and i have really shitty digestion so
but i'd hate soda
i don't like sweet drinks okay so i
also have been into making iced herbal
tea as
i also try not to have caffeine after
like 10 a.m hashtag insomniac
my cutoff is probably a lot more
conservative than emma's um but anyways
as for the apple cider vinegar this is
actually the first
kind of wellness-y ritual that emma
seems to have in her day
even though she admittedly thinks it's a
bit weird
um so that just says a lot right there
but interestingly
like when emma says that she takes it to
help with her digestion
i just feel like that is an honest
observation
on her part as for the claim itself it's
most likely that the increase in water
intake from this drink
is what helps improve her digestion and
move things along
more so than the apple cider vinegar
specifically
as there is no strong research to show
that apple cider vinegar can help
with bloating and digestion in fact one
small study
looked at the effect of apple cider
vinegar in people with gastroparesis
which is a condition that impairs the
movement of food from the stomach into
the intestines
and the study found that apple cider
vinegar could actually slow
down digestion rather than speeding it
up
which can actually lead to increased
bloating and gas
particularly in individuals with these
types of gi disorders
however people who don't have gi
dysfunction may find that apple cider
vinegar can help their digestion
but these claims are largely anecdotal
so if you like the flavor
like emma does then i think it's a great
way to help you up your water intake in
the day
much better than taking like a shot of
the stuff which can be
a lot more aggressive on your stomach
and your teeth
let's talk dinner dinner time if i'm
cooking for myself
it's usually something pretty low
maintenance i'll take like some frozen
vegetables of some sort heat those up
cut up some tofu fry that i will also
make pasta i love garbanzo bean pasta
and i put pesto on it in nutritional
yeast and i'll eat a whole bowl of that
and call it a night
i love how easy and simple
she makes meal prep this totally sounds
like something that
most people could easily put together
pretty inexpensively
and really quickly so we've got some
protein in the tofu
carbs in the brown rice that's in the
curry sauce and sesame oil
and lots of veg and there's basically no
prep work
involved i also love that she's a fan of
frozen veg because
frozen vegetables and produce is not
only really affordable convenient
and has a longer shelf life than fresh
vegetables
but it's a great way to enjoy your
favorite veggies year round regardless
of whether or not they're in season
and you don't have to worry about them
being significantly less healthy there's
also some research to show that some
frozen veggies like broccoli and kale
may actually be more nutrient dense than
fresh veggies
because they're flash frozen right after
they're harvested
to lock in some of that nutrition now if
they're blanched before freezing
then yes that can reduce some of the
nutrients in some veggies
but in general i think whatever little
time
and money saving hacks help you get in
more vegetables
that is a more important consideration
than
the fresh versus frozen debate speaking
of frozen veggies though
if she did want to boost up the veg in
her pesto pasta
she could definitely throw in some
frozen peas or
kale or if the pesto is made from
scratch she could add some spinach
or kale to that as well either way i
love that she's using bonza pasta and
nutritional yeast for some added protein
these are actually two of my personal
favorite protein hacks in pasta dishes
as well
especially when i'm in a rush and i
don't have time to cook a whole other
protein let's see what else yesterday
quite a few
different kind of comfort meals number
one
would have to be monty's burgers
i also love falafel falafel wrap
with hummus and tahini on it and like
pita bread with the hummus
also burritos like from a really good
place also i love breakfast potatoes so
like sometimes
i just want to order just that okay
kudos to harper's bazaar for replacing
the verbiage about cheat meals with
comfort foods instead you probably know
i'm not a fan of the word cheat meals
and while even comfort food has been
often hijacked by diet culture to be
synonymous with
bad foods or junk foods it is worth
noting that the term
can also just be foods that bring you
joy
no moral slant needed as for emma's
comfort meals
i love seeing her excitement about food
i mean as a self-professed picky eater i
do
think that her comfort meals actually
offer some really good variety
from different cuisines and are also all
great well-rounded vegetarian options
as well so of course we've got the
standard veggie burger which
in my opinion a good burger comforts any
and
every soul on the planet so i think we
can all relate right there
the falafel wrap is also an amazing
option
and offers some really good plant-based
protein and healthy fats from the hummus
and tahini
and then of course a good burrito always
hits the spot
um i think burritos are also pretty
inherently well balanced and definitely
super satiating and if she or you want
to make these comfort foods
everyday foods all i would suggest is
adding in more veg i mean i am all about
small little tweaks and additions
rather than omissions to make cheat
meals
into everyday balanced meals that are
just
equally as comforting now overall emma
chamberlain
not only seems super down-to-earth and
refreshing
but her approach to food and eating is
totally something i can get on board
with
unlike a lot of these celebrity food
diaries we've seen so far which
tend to be rife with misinformation
around food
and wellness culture but i love that
emma
totally marches to the beat of her own
drum and despite her growing popularity
in the youtube space she keeps it real
and
really relatable i am officially
a fan and on that note thank you again
to ritual for sponsoring this video
if you liked it and want to see me
review more of these harper's bizarre
clips
please like this video and leave me a
comment below on who to check out next
until then don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on a video
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye